who else is here carlson's nightmare
such a okay such such a good profile
picture here
so probably another guy who likes
queen's gambit
he likes queen's gambit but he doesn't
like psychology opening probably
how much are you currently preparing for
candidates well i don't
i don't think i'm preparing for
candidates right now
because well of course i had some
serious preparation for their
what do you say what what it was
supposed to be like to november
but it didn't uh it turned out it's not
possible yeah because
i guess the problem was that uh players
from china
basically were not allowed to leave the
country
so the things didn't go into
into a good way so now i'm more
let's say focused on the uh
upcoming uh champions tour and
probably to the super final which i'm
not still
i'm not sure if i'm going to play there
or not
okay let's play greedy goose game here
so we collected two pawns
so this is just uh
okay this is just
a good question like for for every day
what
what am i preparing for what is worth
to be preparing for you know what is
really worth to spend time preparing
of course candidates is but you never
know if it's going to happen okay i
missed rook d2 so now he's
suddenly having some fun counter play
ah so he wants to trade yeah okay as uh
as you guys could uh could see before
i'm
already i'm almost happy if any sort of
end game occurs
so let's check close this
this we miss you on twitch any plans for
streaming well i mean uh
i actually streamed a little
in november but i'm not i'm not yet sure
like
um if i'm ready to do it on a regular
basis so i
you know i stopped streaming in order to
make some better preparation again now
my point remote
so well uh
i i i don't know if i get back so maybe
i'll try to record some recaps
of the tournament some
round recaps but you know it's like
three days five
five games every day okay let's promote
rook
and there is uh not so much fun
okay let's take here
yeah queen check takes
let's make three moves all right thank
you
oh already second game oh amazing
who could new